[Music]
Runk well guys hey how's it going uh I
will be in the Cina Laugh Factory
October 12th to the 14th uh working on
some new stuff I will be in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Cleveland Ohio Detroit
Michigan Orlando Florida Fort Meers and
a bunch of different dates coming up
Philadelphia Trenton New Jersey is on
sale now Trenton New Jersey home Home
State uh so go to Chris lea.com to get
those tickets uh and then we've got the
absolutely the uh most uh uh wanted uh
merch which is awesome we've got the
pockets stay deep teas um and the decals
for the car it's just great dude Show
Your Love show your part of this cult
life rips merch life rips hoodies and uh
pants and all that and join our cult
flannels which are absolutely ill uh
Chris lea.com and without that welcome
to everyone's favorite health and
wellness podcast
[Music]
congratulations conratulations
speaking of Health and Wellness uh I
will say since this is everyone's
favorite health and
wellness podcast uh my son I I was about
to start the podcast 20 minutes ago
until I opened the door before I started
just to check on stuff and my son Calvin
was feeding my son William petroleum
jelly so there we go so that's good so I
went out there and
I it's never as bad as you think it is
well I shouldn't say never you
know I'm good at not going to Defcon 10
anymore immediately for stuff you know
and uh Calvin just says look look Dad
I'm feeding him milk and I look and he's
got his finger in the petroleum jelly in
the Vaseline and I say wait oh okay cool
and I was like wait a minute what and he
was like I'm feeding Billy petrol uh uh
milk and I look and I said oh well show
me what you're doing and sure enough he
stuck it in scooped it and went to go
put it in his mouth and man I went to uh
say I said oh no no no buddy that's not
food that that's not food that's that's
don't do that and he got oh dude I
actually it's actually weird
because I was trying to not well I
didn't want to flip out I didn't want to
scare Calvin but then
also don't feed your
brother
wax you don't feed your brother mineral
oil now the only reason why I know
mineral oil and certain natural waxes in
Vaseline and petroleum CU I looked it up
cuz I looked it up cuz after my son gave
my son Vaseline so now I'm more
knowledgeable really so really there's
an upside to everything I could be like
oh no you know Billy's gonna get a
stomach ache or I could be like you know
what now I have knowledge what makes
Vaseline and also besides that what
makes uh if it's dangerous or not it's
not so bad I went to call Kristen she
wasn't home and um and I said this
happened and she said well just look it
up and I looked it up and it's fine
anyway dude so if your son feeds or if
you're you know anyone gets into some
petroleum jelly it's actually probably a
nice delicate test of some certain
certain areas but uh delicacy delices
and idiot uh that's of Delhi so that's a
place where you go to get meat and all
that
stuff been eating real nice dude I'll
tell you what dude I ate real nice and
I've been eating real nice all right now
I'm Natty okay I know everyone is like
how is he so he's he's not Natty right
and he's
like cuz he's Ved out his shoulders
going on for days and he's got film
Crews on the back but
also I just lift up my shirt and you
don't see palumboism right so I'm
obviously Natty okay my stomach isn't
sticking out like I like I'm 3 months
four months pregnant
all right my sides aren't hardened
because they're storing too many carbs
or whatever the [__] that that
palumboism is by the way do you know
what palumboism is it's when your your
stomach you're so Juiced that your
stomach is distended and it's popping
out and it's and I was like why is it
called Palumbo palumboism because the
first guy on record to get it was named
somebody Palumbo and I'm like oh dude
worst like at least luk Garrick's
disease can like kill you palumboism you
just kind of look like dosm you
know and that's so
gross right and so now you just look it
up look up palumboism here we'll show
you a little bit of it but it's like
distended tummies and [__] and it's like
you're all buff but also you brag so
it's disgusting dude really buff guys
are [__] absolutely disgusting what
are you doing dude what are you doing
hey guy chill out what are you doing
what do you make [__] [__] 30 grand a
year you know these guys are like I'm
compeed for the ifbb PB
Pro something shouldn't be what are
those anagrams and acronyms whatever
those things are there's too many of
them too many letters done I'm competing
for the ifpb PBP
Pro I I was the winner of the [__]
ibf PBF Pro in Utah SLC I PBF PPO SLC
Utah USA
PBO
it's tooo much dude you hey also you're
short dude the people ever you look at
up all the people who are bodybuilders
are like 5'9 and 5'8 and [__] and it's
like just chill hey e you're short if
you're really big and a bodybuilder
here's the other thing you're going to
die soon you want me to look at the
thing if you're really big and you're
going to be a bodybuilder if you're like
six 65 you're going to die soon
dude you know work out a healthy amount
eat enough
chicken uh where where's the link you
want me to post click at the top oh
favorite bodybuilder video dude oh yeah
this [__] but there's music to it
right yeah he does
the dude this guy's like so big it's
doesn't matter if there's music we'll
get
demonetized you'll cut out the
music you cut out the music and you just
make it silent is what you're saying
okay I'll just make it silent then here
we go muslem Mania here we go CH soon at
the 16 musclemania University show
Universe show idiot so he's he's posing
these guys look absolutely terrible like
it doesn't look good what the
[__] so not natural everyone's doing
steroids you know and why do they
pretend like they're
not
littlest penises too and not because
they're necessarily little but because
the muscles are so big it makes it look
and this is all let me just so okay
before we even really get into this
video the worst thing is being this buff
okay the second worst thing honestly I
think the two there's two worst things
in the world
that uh in the category
of uh
so hard hard to do and so hard to
achieve and matters the least okay being
extra buff number one number two and
I've always said this break dancing dude
you're so it's so hard you've so many
years so many years
training you know not taking away from
how much dedication you have that's why
all these bodybuilders talk about
dedication because it's all they
have I'm So Dedicated dude I'm [__]
dedicated yeah all right cool
flat now you're bigger okay also you're
like 30 pounds bigger it's not that much
you know or you're or you're you you
lost fat so and every time I talk about
this people are like all right bro
you're a [__] hater you're a
beta I I work out so I'm I'm not
like I'm not upset about any of this
[__] it's just bodybuilding and also
break dancing and I believe this video
is
both
no doesn't he do
both whatever it
is so insecure this guy oh oh oh oh oh
doesn't know what to do and starts
dancing
his muscles are fantastic dude so
insecure this looks like AI this
straight up looks like AI the worst
routine God he's so muscular dude chw
soon oh bodybuilding yeah
yeah dude he's break dancing a little
bit
bro that's so
dumb the guy works so hard at the most
things that don't matter I love it
the head thing is great this head swivel
thing unreal uh so
anyway I don't know it's just
like I'm
Natty took [__] Crea creatine for
four days probably stopped doing that
but that's Natty
dude right it's Natty I don't know my my
friend was talking about how he knew
somebody on trt and he's just like so
strong and I'm like that's cool but but
then synthetically you'll make trt and
then your body won't you you'll make
testosterone and then your body won't
make testosterone naturally so that's
great that's cool and so it's like you
got to keep taking it and I guess that's
okay if you keep taking it but
also now you got to keep taking that
[__] drug it's like me
and stal pram uh anyway switching meds
though too many [__] thoughts in my
head uh I think working out is cool so
all right that's enough of that [__]
dude um look at look at what this says
on my notes I didn't write this my
producer did one fire probably want to
stay away from talking about Israel
Palestine
Hamas ah probably it's all me it's all
just terrible
um I want to look at this though Drake's
album came out do you like Drake's album
I listened to three of them that one
with J
Cole's is really
good my yo dog I had to look up how old
this was when I finished listening to
the
album you are
36 your birthday is in 20 days I Googled
that too you would be 37 years old Joe
Buton talk about Drake get the away from
some of these younger n and stoping
these 25 year
olds I'm listening to the album
you're a 37 year old
billionaire I get it that you appeal to
the world about Co like my [__] is
happening in Reverse like with Cole he
used to rap about kid [__] I'm a grown
ass like real Jersey City I don't want
to hear how you lost youring virginity
and then he started to grow up and then
the rapping sounded like an adult
rapping I'm want to hear adult Drake
rapping for adult
people no the guy just go no
dude uh what do you think about that I
don't
know
uh did Drake respond in the comments you
said uh oh it's in the comments yeah I I
I feel like
um I don't know but you're number one
you get [__]
uh hated on also he's I don't know he's
36 I guess he you know he's just [__]
and what do you want him to rap about
world peace and
[__]
fracking yeah oh we yo are you are you
are you Pro or anti
fracking
yeah what dude what is it straight up
every time someone tells me what
fracking is I go like this oh cool and
then immediately I forget it so that's
great I'm a [__] idiot dude um the
Drake album The the Cole the J Cole song
and Drake is so good and then everything
else is sing song He seems like and then
21 Savage is on one of them and I don't
get that guy so I'm old I'm a boomer
what do you want for me I'm not a boomer
but I'm a boomer in a way
um I guess there was a Streaker at the
Today Show but that's honestly
what was I oh yeah I was I was talking
about that here's the thing about
Today's Show
though
um don't have that [__] stupid ass
window you're asking for
it you're absolutely asking for it here
it is on
YouTube come on play
it it's cool it's not
playing here we
go why is there no sound on it is there
no sound on
it I just had something brand new from
there he goes new podcast where oh
god oh there's a almost naked winner
just had something brand new from there
he goes new podcast where you close the
cop the cop should just be running after
what is happening oh my gosh
hold okay well they that's the thing
don't have that window I I don't like
that
[__] cuz anybody they deserve that a guy
naked running by because it's like have
walls in backa you're a studio dude I
don't you know what I want to see well I
want to see that way more than I want to
see
this um I I don't like that at all I
don't like that at all um anyway um
let's go back to the [__] thing cuz
so yeah I've been eating clean is what I
was trying to [__] say um um and I've
been eating like you know uh uh
salmon uh thises good I know it's boring
right now salmon broccoli sweet potatoes
or as anybody in my family from New
Jersey would say sweet
potatoes
um and that kind of stuff okay really
nothing to I think I had a chicken
sandwich
once then besides that super good no
sweets period period no sweets
so I'm like Saturday night I say to my
first of all I say to my buddy hey when
do you want to hang out Friday Saturday
or Saturday and he says um well I
can't Sunday but either Friday or
Saturday so I say all right Friday let's
all right I say all right Saturday let's
do it and he says okay sorry I say all
right Friday let's do it and he says
okay and then I say to my wife hey let's
get dinner on Saturday and do like a
date night and she's like awesome then
my buddy hits me back and says oh dude
sorry man actually got to hang out with
the girl that I'm that I'm starting to
see can't do it Friday so let's do it
Saturday and I go like this no you made
your bed I asked you to see what's up
you're GNA be P ussy whipped okay you're
G to do that on someone that you don't
even love
probably okay then guess what you don't
get to hang out now
I go like this sorry man I asked you
first and now I have a date with my wife
then and that's what's up I'm pissed but
I'm also in love dude so I'm GNA be so
pissed in Love on
Saturday and I'm not going to see you
Friday night what am I going to do
Friday night I hang out with my [__]
wife I guess so now two times I'm G to
hang out with my wife in love I'm pissed
that's
fine so Saturday night I'm like you want
to go I oh no you know what Friday night
I went to go visit my buddy [__] I
didn't actually but this is where you
know you learn stuff as you
talk so I went to uh this place on
Friday night met up with my buddy was
his birthday and I said I'm going to
take my wife out on Saturday we're going
to do like a date night where should I
go and he says I don't know so I'm like
all right so I look up on Open Table I'm
43 dude he does Open Table right that's
an app where you look up and you can
make reservations on places and I'm like
does it even have nice place
or is it just a [__] places cuz if
it's on Open Table how special am I if
everyone can use it maybe I'm not
special and that's fine maybe I need to
be humbled just by opening up an app and
that's you know it is what it is so I
open up the app I got a lot of four star
five star restaurants or whatever how
many stars it goes up to whatever the
fullest amount of stars is that's the
amount of stars it has on a lot of our
restaurants I look at the dollar signs
it's got the most amount of dollar signs
I'm like I'm not going to take my wife
to some [__] you know Chipotle or or
or uh what's the other one the vegan
place vegan house what the hell is it I
don't know who cares the the the one
everywhere what is
it [__] is that place
called vegan place you know what I'm
talking about hold on God damn it I'm
pissed now I I swear I need gko b b Boga
Bela
Boba uh not what's the [__]
chain God damn it look at all these ones
that you can't even Google it without in
Los Angeles it still gives you the hip
ones it's like V glory and God damn it
what is the [__] one that is
everywhere you know what I'm talking
about I I have you don't know what I'm
talking about the vegan chain yeah you
don't know
no oh my god
dude don't you don't eat it goes and out
of
my I'm so P dude you have witness me
Veggie
Grill you know Veggie Grill right
I've seen he's seen it he
says he admits it he goes I've seen
it I've seen it Veggie Grill [__] man
there's so many of them I'm not taking
her to Veggie girl it's my point so now
I'm like all right let's look it up I
look up I go to this place I say I say
is Everly good the guy go the guy says
oh it's so good sit on the back patio so
I like all right well you should have
just said the place all right fine
whatever so I looked at the other guy
said is Everly good oh so good I said
all right I'm going to Everly it's
Italian so I go like this Saturday night
I'm just going to carb it up I don't
give a [__] I'm not going to be one of
those guys that's like yeah going to a
nice place that get to go to the place
known for what the place is for Italian
food and then I'm just going to like you
know get a salad I don't do that [__] I
don't like those kinds of guys so I'm
going to load it up all
right so I go there and I'm like I don't
have to load all up right I can eat some
I could I could you know cheat a little
bit on the food right but not crazy
amount dude once I sat down I didn't
even think about curbing it at all I go
I look at the menu and I say can I have
the sopra seta pizza and also the Ragu
with the wide
noodles and he says
great it came the pizza was for me and
her I ate all of it I ate the whole
pizza with the sopra seta and honey and
chili I ate the whole [__] thing and
then the and then the pasta came and I
was like I'm only going to eat half of
this and I didn't even stop I ate the
whole [__] thing okay then the guy
said want dessert and I go like this I'm
already all in what am I doing yeah what
do you have and he says ice cream
sandwich with the cook I go stop right
there bring it he says two I say one I
say one because I think we can share it
but secretly I know she's not going to
even have a bite
so one for
me it comes it's way too big I don't
like ice cream sandwiches that are at
fancy places because one thing you don't
[__] with is a an ice cream sandwich
from a store it's
unfuckwitable it's unfuckwitable it's so
beautiful right so you're not going to
fancy it Gussy it up like brownies
unfuckwitable right what else is
unfuckable uh [__] that they that that
the thing I need to talk to my brother
about my brother's always like you don't
like the good Gourmet [__] that's what I
got to say because it's they're making
[__] Gourmet that's unfuckable that's
the thing I got to say to him is is
unfuckable that's a cool thing to say
anyway
um yo eight the [__] it came the
cookie was too big and it was a little
Frozen and then the thing dude didn't
stop me from not eating ate
it the boy walks around at 2:05 okay he
walks walks around at 205 he's big he's
a tall drink of water you can't really
tell when he gains 10 lbs because of him
walking around at 6'2 6'3 and I'm still
growing I'm getting
taller all right
and yeah he's angular but he walks
around like a you know and he also has a
swag he walks like a ball player
and he was 213 214 he was couldn't tell
you know when I when I shot my special I
was 2113 214 all good couldn't really
tell Kaz it even out
right started eating beautiful just
really good would making Myan ancestors
be like you got hey you losing way you
eat the [__] eat them eat more
right clock got a [__] smart scale
too God damn it this is interesting got
a smart scale stood on it got it to do
the body weight the the the the bone
dude bone density it's got water
percentage skeletal
density BMI yeah heart rate got it all
you get on the scale it shows your
weight and then you wait a little bit
and it shows the rest of the stuff not
once have I waited I got off of me so I
don't even know the rest of the [__] I
got it paid for the extra [__] that's
how respectful I am I get on the scale
it
goes I weigh myself and then it says
calculating the rest of it yo your boy
takes the 205 and steps off you're not
going to tell me what my heart rate is
you're not going to tell me what my
skeletal muscles are I want to know how
much I weigh all right even though you
trick me into buying it okay so now 203
he gets down to hard work dedication
perseverance never
stopping sweating it out getting Fancy
with the kettle bells you know what I'm
talking about all right super setting on
super
sets so I go to Everly okay I [__] with
one
meal like my name is you
know butch or something I mean I [__]
with one meal like my name is Vinnie
like one meal where I'm just like where
like I'm wearing a pinky ring like I
don't give a [__] one
meal I get home I step on the
scale I'm
six and a
half
pounds
that sucks
God hey God come on
please hey God it was one meal yeah it
was a whole Pete a bunch of rigaton and
half of a huge ice cream sandwich but
hey God come on
man yo for real are you [__] me
thank God I walk around like a ball
player so I still can keep it so [__]
absolutely ridiculously sexy just with
my swag and whatnot I'm a fat guy now
again
dude I'm not even Ved out anymore I'm
like a [__] upside down
tent with people in
it
two days I haven't been getting to I I
couldn't get back I I it's been three
days I can't get back to
203 I go like this I say what the [__]
somebody I know knows a lot about
nutrition I said what the [__] she's
like it's all about the salt and I'm
like it's not dude you know don't tell
me that it's all about the salt the
salt's what kills you I'm like you know
what I I shouldn't be talking about this
with anybody because everybody's just
going to be [__] wrong about
it so I ate clean as [__] today today I
didn't I didn't even eat to 12:30 dude
and I woke up at
11:00 I ate some overnight oats before I
[__] went to workout got crazy with
it hour 20 minutes came by g eight 8
ounces of salmon this is so interesting
and then two three sweet potato slices
and a little bit of roasted vegetables
dude I'm
Natty you know health and wellness
podcast boy I didn't even know how much
of a health and wellness podcast I was
going to be talk talking about this but
it is and it's true and that's what's
great about it so anyway that place was
really great got to do date night night
more what is it about when you do stuff
you get tricked into thinking yeah I got
to do this more and then you just don't
you know you know what I'm talking about
you ever go for a walk for the [__] of
it if you go for a walk and you don't
normally go for walks and you're walking
around with your spouse or kids or
friend whatever and you don't at least
think you probably say it but if you
don't at least think we got to do this
more I got to do this more you're a
you're an absolute robot you're a
sociopath that is The Human Condition to
do something like that and think I got
to do this more and then you start
thinking [__] like well you know humans
were built to do this like it was really
when we were our ancestors and you know
they build Huts but they spend most of
the time outside in caves and you know
that's what you do and then you just go
back and you just don't do it again
that's
American that's it
that's American and every time I say
that something about American I always
think one time I was in a strip club and
I was with a uh a buddy of mine we went
to a we went to a strip club and he went
back to get a lap dance and he went with
the worst
one and I'm talking about this was
in deep North
Hollywood okay for people that aren't in
Hollywood they don't even know there's a
North Hollywood hey guys there's a North
Hollywood they know West Hollywood they
might not but they don't know North
Hollywood well guess what there is one
all right and it's riddled with you
know
like checks cash places and bail bonds
and strip clubs okay we went one to one
and he oh man it was so funny dude he
was
like went to the strip club it was me
him and another guy and we were like wow
that one's like crazy but he was
hustling you know what I'm talking about
the the the the the I guess I would say
the worst looking you are as a stripper
the more you got to be every day I'm
hustling every day I'm hustling every
day every day every day I'm
hustling just on the [__] pole and
that was a banger at the strip club too
just chicks come out with you know 16
teeth just pear shaped every day I'm
hustling every day I'm every day like
well yeah she needs to you know and then
a [__] dope
ass just bodied out caramel Sunday comes
out and you're just like that's the one
but
anyway just a beautiful [__]
hourglass shaped cookies and cream just
walting out and you're oh you know they
do that [__] to that one song
[Laughter]
they come out
to they come out to that
[Laughter]
song
[Music]
Can a [__] dude some Portis head my god
dude if you want to hook up with a chick
and you're in a room with her and you're
single and she's chilling and she's got
no interest in it all you got to do is
pour some wine and just play a little
bit of porise head and dude get the
towels
[Music]
out darling I'll be right back I'm going
to the bathroom to grab some
towels cuz the fine chicks either dance
to that or
so seductive that
one anyway
um so the the the the ugly ones come out
to every day I'm hustling you know
because they have to and [__] so she
came out we were just like oh god dude
it was like Friday we're like damn you
know and
uh sure enough dude she [__]
my friend so hard I went back with some
[__] you know she swindled me out of
some money I remember I would go to the
strip club and the [__] the the
awesome the best looking
one would [__] go back I'd give her
the cash and then she'd be like you only
give me this and she would hide some of
the money and I I knew it but I was like
all right here you go uh I saw her like
recently like a year or two ago and she
wow looks awful I just saw her walking
around so that's what you get
swindling uh uh
anyway he went back with um so every
time I think of when I think of American
male this is what going back to goddamn
it I mean I'm so devolving this whole
[__] podcast
but he I'm getting a dance with the
[__] good one and then I come out and
I'm like where the hell's my friend and
my other friend says you're not going to
believe this he went back with the
[__] Rick Ross dancing ass girl and I
go
what dude he comes out after a few
minutes just on his face just shame you
know and he says that he starts off the
conversation
with who well I didn't want to but and
we dude we had to sit down because
nothing's funnier than that you
understand
you you didn't want to oh hey but guys
you're dead you know if you don't want
it don't go I didn't want to but and
dude we we we immediately sat down tears
before laughing because it was that
funny when we just had to explode you
know and he was like and she and she
convinced me to go back and then I did
and then she was like it's going to be
so good and and then and then and then
and then dude he was back there and she
was she was grinding on
him and and she was like he explained
that her butt was on on his out his
penis was out you know and I was like
God damn dude all right you
know and he was like and I sh dude he
says and I finally when when when I just
this is how we talk when I just it shot
it shot over her ass it shot over her
ass and dude and I
never and and the and the reason why I
always think of the the American M cuz I
saw that stripper later and she was like
Hey dude I know how it is uh every guy
that comes in here is a hot blooded
American male and I know how to work it
dude and I always think of that when I
think of American or American male and
then I think over her over her ass dude
and we were
laughing when I tell you we were
laughing that's over as over her ass
dude I think about that so much
dude [__] yeah dude he just shot a load
and
[Applause]
just I shot over her ass over her
ass oh man it was so good
dude previously on shooting over her
ass pre pre
previous previously on red previously on
hot blooded American
[Music]
maale I said over her over her ass dude
oh God I just love it
man oh just holding on for dear life
just
squirting um oh wow that was great to
relive that [__] you know this why I
like this podcast a lot of the time is
because it just makes me think of things
that have happened in my life that I
forget that I relive so thank you for
that
man God I used to [__] I used to love
going to strip clubs I used to go all
the time and I just don't anymore I mean
I haven't been in so well I think I went
two years ago with my wife and some
friends and it was to that place on the
body shop in the body shop uh on Sunset
and that place used to be awesome and I
guess it's I don't know I've gone once
but a f it caught fire and then
it and then it [__] it's not been the
same but that's boring but
anyway strip clubs are cool but I don't
I don't
know uh my mom's doing good I know I
shared with you that she fell and broke
broke her head she's doing very well she
told me to stop getting tattoos it's
hilarious she goes like this Chris don't
do your whole body until I'm dead that's
how she brought it up and I didn't even
understand what she was talking about
and then I go oh yeah tattoos and I was
like
Ma you know what is it The Sopranos she
was just like Chris don't do your whole
body until I'm dead and I said Ma and
she said at this rate I'm going quickly
it won't be too
long and we laughed instead of cried and
then and then I went to go to the
bathroom and I'm like dude when when
your parents fall and break a hip like
all the furniture has to change and [__]
if they's 75 it's just like you got to
remodel the house you you fall you break
the hip the whole house changes you got
two level levels you're [__] you got
to have one level you can't go up to
what are you going to be one of those
[__] [__] that sits on the side
of the railing and just you know what I
mean you're like this and
then up the stairs like a piece of [__]
dude no no way no way dude I'm never
doing that all right no matter how old I
get no matter how per pgic I'll [__]
army crawl up the stairs or drag me up
there I'm not [__]
sitting and
going all right
but you know if you have two levels and
you break your hip you're [__] you're
you're reduced to just chilling on that
one level so you better pick the right
one so we moved all the furniture and
[__] she's got like nine potties around
now cuz it's just like I never know when
I'm going to have to [__] I don't know I
have to walk too far and I'm like all
right she's joking
obviously and she's doing good now but I
went to I was like I got to go to the
bathroom I had to go number two not to
be crash and I went in and I lo I looked
at the potty and I was like what the
[__] is this thing I
forgot dude the potties that they give
people that break their hips they they
look like
you if you fell asleep and dreamed of a
potty they're like so big and
weird I don't really get how it helps
with the with
the with the thing but I guess it does
I'm not a doctor you
know shout out to my mom dude she's
doing great I'm I'm really proud of her
it's cool Calvin's been walking around
running around the house one day he woke
up and he was just like hey D all the
food's chocolate and I was like huh and
he he he picks up toys and just
goes try some want to try some I go dude
all the food all the toys all the toys
are chocolate we're going to get Grandma
and Pop's house we call them gam and pop
he says you think that all the toys at
Gammy's house are chocolate I said well
man you know it's up to you he gets
there he says gamy all the food's CH all
the all
the all the [__] toys are chocolate
just the whole time dude are
hilarious what was I doing not having
kids I like when people choose not to
have kids because of the carbon
footprint and all that stuff and not
everybody needs to be having kids but
man if you would be a good Dad or Mom
have kids
because it's so awesome
man my kid loves wacky Inflatables we
got a wacky inflatable Tu man I was with
with Adam W internet Tik Tock YouTube
star and uh he did uh a set on my tour
in
Nashville and my son was there it was me
and Calvin and he was showing him Adam W
that he liked to do the whacking
inflatable and Adam was like you know I
have one of those I'm like huh and he's
like dude I have a warehouse full of
[__] because of my YouTube skits and I
did one with whacking FL wall I'm just
going to send it to you so he sent it to
me dude and
I surprise Calvin or I guess he did
surprise Calvin with this wacky
inflatable thing it's 35 feet in the air
and we have it out on my front lawn like
we're selling
Subarus and it's
just and dude
Calvin loses his mind when this thing
turns on he just keeps looking at it
saying what is it what is it so happy
and that's what makes me happy cuz all I
care about is my kid's happiness and and
also other things too that are ingrained
in me ever since I was a kid that I
really hard to get like I want people I
want people to accept me but
um yeah dude remember when I couldn't
think of Veggie Grill dude I wonder if
I'm going to get dementia like I already
feel it creeping in I can't think of
things like Veggie Grill I can't ever
remember that one dude's name who's the
actor um I can't do it I can't I can't
do it I cannot remember this guy there's
an actor I'm thinking of right now no
matter how many times I think of him I
cannot remember his name he's famous
dude great this this is you you have one
of these things in your brain where your
brain just doesn't think of
them I'm going to describe the guy and
I'm G and and and you're going to get it
before I am he's in Galaxy Quest he's in
The Green Mile he's in the three
Billboards of [__] whatever that
thing is right he he he's he's kind of
different looking but
arguably got a thing going you know and
not sexy quite but like was nominated
for an Oscar I think for I can never
remember the guy's name dude you know
who I'm talking about
right you do don't say it because I want
to get it in real time this is how long
it takes for me to get this guy's name
all right so [__] I cannot believe my
brain does this every single time it's
been years dude
Steve uh
um uh uh
uh
I he's in the thing with Tom Hanks he
plays a
convict you know who I'm talking about
now right why can't I ever get this
guy's name what is it about that what do
you think it is about that that I can't
access that I can never think of this
one guy's name it's only him Gregory
peek I think of him good that guy I can
just do anyone right I can you say guy I
oh yeah okay it's a [__] Rip Torn I
know
him you know these are these guys are
dead I haven't thought of these guys in
years this guy I think of all the time I
can't think of his [__]
name
Steve uh Sam Sam Rockwell got it dude
hell yeah that was the fastest I ever
got it that was the fastest I ever got
it and I've even thought I've even
thought um
he it's the same name as my dog why
that's all I have to remember and I
still can't do it I forget that or
something [__] yeah dude I need to take
gingo baloba dude what is that do you
have things like that leave it in the
comments if you do I can never [__]
access that guy's name so that's what
makes me think I'm going to have
dementia which is fine like I said here
before dementia is the only disease that
is probably you're chilling dude because
other it's everyone else it's for
everyone else that's that's that's a
sadness oh Dad doesn't know who he is um
Dad look and cut to Dad just like
this what's my
name just absolutely [__] can you can
still you know jerk off watch
TV and you don't even have to be nice to
people cuz they go like oh that's not
really him anymore don't even worry
about it that's why he called you a
raging bleep it
out but it's just like oh yeah that's
not him hey hey dude I can't I need to
get that's the one people say like
alcoholism is cool because you always
get to be drunk and [__] and you're
always partying dude dementia topnotch
disease hey [__] get in here you could
just you know what I mean oh it's he's
it's not
him it's not the real him he was much
nicer in in when it was really him for
me it' be like he was a little
nicer um you can just be racist if you
want you know it's
fine Tourette's is kind of cool too
because you can just do that I think I
actually have a little bit of Tourette's
to be honest
um
secrets
secrets OCD is C of tourettes
Secrets if you have OGD you have a
higher chance of Tourette's Secrets
didn't know zent recently talked about
it with my psychiatrist and she great
secrets I have invisible ticks you can't
see them
Secrets it's the realness dude what are
we going to do I've T I've done 380
hours of this podcast what else am I
going to talk about besides [__] you
know
the odd bodybuilding bit and then uh a
story about how I went to a strip club
and then uh you know the realness he's
got to touch on the
realness 380s P crazy that I you know
380 hours of this podcast
and you
know and still [__] going we love you
babies dude you guys keep us going and
if you're in the patreon that's amazing
you guys keep it really going
patreon.com christalia appreciate you
guys um thank you for the
patreons um get tattooed by the
Pennsylvania's best Andy morisy
Instagram Andy marsy 1990 go to my page
if you want to purchase a 10-word ad
like that shout out kind of thing uh
it's uh holler. christalia that's what
it is
um yeah so anyway we're chilling
dude and I got new glasses and I'm just
[__] Off to the Races you
know I drive around and
[__] my life is good dude you know
can't wait to get back on the road going
to Detroit
next I like it I like Detroit I like I
like Cleveland I'm going to Cleveland I
like I like Cleveland even though most
people in
Cleveland um statistically are not smart
um because of uh the The Brain Drain you
ever heard of that the brain drain yep
it's a thing where when you get to be
20-some you the
smart affluent intellectual people want
to leave
Cleveland and so there aren't people who
further Society in
Cleveland uh and then people will retire
and go back to Cleveland
but there's a brain drain that's stats
can't argue with that but I personally
love Cleveland and I don't care what
they say about you I think it's [__]
I love Cleveland I think you know what's
[__] good in Cleveland the food the
food's good in Cleveland I think
Cleveland is a one of the most slept on
cities that I've been
to it's it's got all the teams you got
football baseball hockey red you know
badminton all this
[__] and uh
I don't know it still gets like a funny
like [__] you if you say Cleveland is
shitty I spent many time the people are
nice as
[__] a lot of them are fat but whatever
dude that's the Midwest
man
um let me click on
this just Tik Tok this is
graphic
here we
[Music]
go
me me oh my God the horse with the
sparkly ass outfit the whole thing's so
stupid look the guy with the American
hat and [__] outfit holding the horse
cuz the horse is kind
of no no dude oh my god dude she's in
stretcher what a cut dude the greatest
cut Wes Anderson directed it
dude how much does that song suck you
know like let's just be
real update
it dude the mer what is it called the
American national anthem dude hey get
Nelly to redo it or something it's so
[__] bad oh the ra horns
[Music]
we the dawn early people don't even know
what it [__] it is they're saying
when they sing
it first of all it starts with
Jose can you see update it dude get
[__] get Chingy out there dude
get dude that song
sucks get that guy who [__] say What
The Hook going to be uhoh get that guy
to redo it with Nelly and the [__] St
lunatics and
[__] Chingy what's the [__] guy
who does a hook G
be the guy with the hook what the what
the hook going be is the
[Music]
song Murphy Lee
Dude I don't need no [__] hook on
this beat uhoh D have that
guy America up in
her [__] Bean stalks and parking lots
we got
[__] malls we got outdoor malls we
got strip malls of
Plenty and [__] hoes that'll suck
your dick and then complain about it
afterwards about how you're shitty we
have
men who never think about their
feelings we have hot red-blooded
Americans that shoot over her as over
her
ass
[Laughter]
H
dude college kids always go
dog
[Laughter]
now didn't her
right dude that would be [__] oh so
lit just the
[__] Seattle Mariners just like
this oh sh the the election was
rigged
and Biden Li hide
people
hide oh Nell didn't Hur
right all the ramp parts we whatever the
[__] it is and the home of
the
just a big [__] loose
fart anyway that song sucks updated come
on
Nelly this
[__] god like you know talk about I
hope she's okay all honesty she got a
stretcher but sometimes they if you're
old and you just like slip and almost
fall they'll call the stretcher on you
because they don't want to take any
chances especially because the [__]
look at the idiot with the American
cowboy hat and the [__] buttondown
short sleeve shirt all right and then
you got a a woman who's all sequenced
out and a horse who's got no business
horsing right and she's just and C
too oh I hope she's okay Wes Henderson
[__] directed it 100% so well got to
send that to my friends on the text chat
for sure 100% doing it right now doing
it on the podcast because I'm respectful
like that dude doing it on the podcast
[Music]
um she
what why she's trying to get the guy
away from her oh no she's trying to get
the guy away from her like she's got
it that trying to help her the guy
probably [__] ruined it honestly he's
probably why the horse she's trying to
get him away from
her
okay listen to it
[Music]
close listen
closely
thank she said thank you oh thank
you did she did she
say no thank you bro that are you sure
bro that's it that is it that is so
funny dude no thank
[Laughter]
you I
oh thank you she say no thank you oh
[__] [__] dude and the rockets no no
thank you red FL
just she's
horizontal dude the [__]
the why did I think there was a truck
backing up
noise [__] oh dude she
[Music]
just first of all
bad she say here we go here we
[Music]
go she
says she
says no thank you
[Music]
dude bro this is one of the funniest
videos I've ever seen in my
life oh my God she says no thank you
dude
H H and the hor is watching it later
watching her like I did
that oh [__] that's
great happy birthday to John Ryan follow
him on Instagram John Ryan is dead Jo n
uh go to my page if you want to purchase
a 10-word ad uh holler. christalia you
um let's look at this one people getting
pissed oh I love this one pinky hi this
is Pinky start again hold
on go this is Pinky he's a male hold on
cat domestic short hair he's available
for adoption he's pet of the week the
one I love about this one is that he
tries to hold on to it so long when he
should just let it go animal shelter
like that's typical male [__] like this
if it was a woman she would just let go
and the cat would run away and men are
not good at this [__] a very loving cat
oh up
up here pinky
pinky who who who we got a wild cat on
our
handsy settle down Bud oh boy careful
careful idiot with the never mind women
the women's not with the Box you
know set it over look set it
over catch to get him
yeah cuz I'm not going to grab
you dude up in from the
day you got see in the back [__] excuse
my language I love excuse my language
what what did the guy say you got see in
the back oh dude that guy I punched that
guy Skyhigh he got you in the back
that's so annoying dude shut the [__] up
let me just get mad at the cat
scratching my [__] taint catching it
back my favorite cat attack ever though
let me try to look it up this is my
favorite one ever
I I props to whoever shot this one um
Christmas
present open
cat attack
neck [__] yeah here it is
dude man is attacked by cat while
opening up his Christmas
gift first of all this guy's 30 okay and
flipping out like a [__] [__]
about getting a video
game he got Uncharted such a dork now
watch
[Laughter]
this dude
the
wow the cat just took him to task he did
not like that the cat hates Uncharted
that's great dude uh all right thanks
for chilling with us uh pod on this
podcast
patreon.com christalia if you want the
rest of the episode and also if you want
all of the we've got two three years of
um two years of uh extra episodes on the
patreon I got to be like 30 something
that are not available to the public so
gone over there for just 6 bucks you get
30 hours of
podcasts uh and all the uncut ones we
appreciate you and thank you very
[Music]
much
[__]